dr. Peterson I'm really hoping you can
share your thoughts on the biggest
shooting yeah well what I would do is
recommend the biblical lecture I did on
Cain and Abel I would say because I
think that that's a good summary of the
state of mind that somebody has to be in
in order to do what was done at Las
Vegas so you have to be very very
embittered by life in order to do that
sort of thing and you have to be
searching for revenge I would say and
it's not you know you might think well
it's only revenge on other people
because you've developed hatred for
people but it's deeper than that it's
not just hatred for people I would say
it's hatred for being itself and the
desire to take revenge on being for the
outrage of the tragedy and suffering
that's associated with being and maybe
the tragedy and suffering that's being
part and parcel of your own life and
that makes you embittered and then past
embittered becomes outraged and past
outrage becomes well homicidal or even
genocide 'el and that's a terrible state
of mind to be in it's a hellish state I
believe that the best way to
conceptualize the state of mind that
someone has to be in in order to do
something like the Columbine shootings
for example or what happened in Las
Vegas is that you're really and now you
have to speak about it religious
languages you're really out for revenge
against God for the outrage of creation
that's what it looks like to me and
that's a state of mind that's truly
hellish and you could get there by
brooding long enough now it's also
possible I mean this guy didn't have any
previous history criminal history or
anything like that he's pretty old so
you know there's also also also the
possibility of some kind of neurological
pathology that that might be
characteristic of him you know some
degenerative neurological disease there
was a kid years ago at the University of
Texas at Austin who climbed up on the
tower there and shot a number of people
with a high-powered rifle and he had a
fast growing tumor on his hypothalamus
and had reported like these being
overcome with extreme feelings of rage
and so that's another possibility but I
would say
the embitterment hypothesis is the
strongest one I would also say - I
noticed the Steven Pinker tweeted this
today is that one of the ways of
controlling this sort of thing would be
for the press to agree not for there to
be a blanket agreement not to publicize
the name or any other identity markers
of the people who do the shooting
because there's also this really what
would you call it arrogance it's a kind
of arrogance and pride last-ditch
arrogance and pride that that is
associated with the fantasies that drive
this sort of behavior and the fantasy is
something like well after I do this
everyone will sure know the who the hell
I was you know even though maybe I was
ignored or unhappy when I was alive
after I'm dead everybody's gonna know
who I was and what I did then you know
so there's this underground desire for
fame I guess its notoriety but notoriety
might be preferable to being ignored and
so you know there's a lot of talk about
gun control and that's understandable
especially with regards to automatic
rifles hmm
although I also understand why the
people who are gun owners are afraid of
allowing what they regard is one of
their fundamental rights to be infringed
upon but it would certainly be useful if
we stop giving people who do this sort
of thing 100 million dollars worth of
free publicity and all the notoriety
they can manage so you know that's
another way of thinking about
controlling it so